there are certain things like aardvark
hot sauce or dream water powder that you
can't get in LA I can't find it then
those are kind of the gifts I like
things that I desire but I can't get you
know yeah she's just throwing it out
there
everybody makes you send it to up yo box
and all the gifts packs we get from
Tiger Burley fans we really appreciate
it
but do you I do the candy I've eaten all
of the candy yes that's not allowed any
gummy this and that did not send any
more Haribo gummy bears no [ __ ] maxed
out maxed out but I also need to lose
weight because I've been obsessed with a
show that's been around for a long time
but Astro it's what him and I first made
love to oh we made love to the show what
was on TV first time we ever did it that
first time ever it's my 600 pound life
you'll see yeah it's the greatest show
ever invented
yeah number one you never see them in
real life because then they can't leave
the house like six people that are like
seven or pounds they don't leave the
house so you don't run into the meth
like Jiffy Lube or you know we're at a
rave or Burning Man you know me wherever
you go you're not gonna see you're not
gonna see the 700-pound guy right so
then when you see it on TV you go it's
real I don't know how they even stay
alive long enough to hit seven eight
hundred pounds yeah also me well why was
600 pound the limit you would think that
you know they were pitching the show how
about four two pound life
[Music]
go up 500 close enough yeah because you
know they have originally it wasn't my
600 pound life initially it was half ton
man has done uncle my half ton mother
and they were over a thousand pounds and
those were the ones that they had to be
extracted from the house like they would
actually have to break walls into the
house to remove their bodies and the I
think when one of the episodes a woman
died like through during the show while
the show was filming so those were
really really intense and and eventually
they were like oh maybe those are too
high-risk let's just go with the 600
pounders I sometimes I see that show and
I go if I was a sibling or a father I
might set us start a side business a
soap business making soap from their fat
yes oh yeah this is true because when
they get the surgery and they remove
like the lymphedema yeah some of those
lymphedema sounds like a Filipino food
dish it's like excess skins they weigh
up to 80 pounds yeah it's amazing just
80 pounds of just fat and mass you could
make a [ __ ] ton of so I'll make so much
soap and um but you know what like a la
here's the thing why I like the show if
you did that did this to just a random a
600 pound guy and it wasn't on TV I
don't think they would do it I feel like
motivation the motivation is the
celebrity of it right because a lot of
people watch the show I know everyone on
the show now like I know you know
whoever like Edie
the guy from Modern Family like they
doneall like you know they're like to me
and that level and we also watch their
where are they now episodes this week in
E we keep track of how they're doing cuz
some of them they gain the weight back
others they they go extreme overboard
and become an irate with the one the
best one was Christina Christina was you
know so good bro this twenty two old
girl she was um 600 plus riot 22 and she
lost
all the way she got down to 190 180 yeah
and she look on a heart she was a very
pretty girl you could tell she was
already very pretty even when she was a
big girl there is like if I wasn't
dating kalila and I'm in love with
kalila and this is like a side thing but
when I watch the show there's a little
bit of fancy yeah where I would I would
meet a hundred-pound woman right with a
nice face you could you can tell if they
have a nice face right and then you just
like ridiculed on what no not ridicule
that but you just gotta go gotta go yeah
I think you need too much pot roast or
whatever you just kind of slowly you
know yeah great at there you know I mean
but you get them to lose the way you're
playing Dom watch watch my thing right
just he said then you get them down to
170 right and then 160 150 even they're
kind of hot
but they still have that mentality so
then you can like abused them oh gods
dangerous like control yeah yeah that's
called having a chocolate chip on your
shoulder weird like no because that's
what I caught I actually coined that
term because my ex-boyfriend that I was
with for five years previous to Bobby he
used to be a fat boy all of his life and
then he had lost like 660 pounds or
something like that and he became a
really really hot dude
but he didn't have the confidence so
that's how I scored a really hot dude
it's because he used to be a fat boy he
was never hot when he was younger I
can't score those hot ones from birth
they got to be an ex fat boy turned hot
because they're the ones who are still
so eager and a little bit unsure they
don't flaunt their [ __ ] that's what I
meant to say not control them what I
said earlier not abuse them mentally
mentally that's not what I meant to say
he meant what exact chuckle chips is
what I meant to say um but it's a great
show and I just you know also that's
show is you get to see results like a
real life change and it's inspiring it
is very inspiring but also you get to
see why people even get to that point
it's usually wire but why it's lack of
coping trauma being it's so
psychological that they're usually the
turning point of of the weight loss and
the moment they decide that okay this is
it it's not it's not that they it's all
psychological it's it's like a [ __ ]
but you would think thing in their head
but you would think just hear me out
mm-hmm let's just say 350 you would
think at 350 in anybody's life you'd
have to think I can guess enough right
I don't know I've made 100 is like what
that's a lot it's easy to knock these
people and say you fat slob but some of
them really really touched me some of
them should be they touch me - you did
it 350 somebody interviewed somebody
saying that's put that [ __ ] hot dog
down yeah but their place that was 230
for me 230 was like yo and even as a
friend if I knew you back then yeah I
wouldn't a said anything like let's see
can get in the show no I would I would
play when you got to 350 yes I would I
would I want to confirm that you that's
it would you do the whole like you're
gonna [ __ ] die no we're like no I'd
have a dungeon yeah I love you that much
so what you're saying that you'd put me
in a basement imprison you yeah I would
have a bed a comfy bed tempur-pedic oh
thank you for another double-double King
temperament make it nice yeah when I say
dungeon it's not gonna be medieval yeah
but you're not gonna get out yeah right
and I'm not gonna you're not gonna be
able to talk to me either
right way I don't communicate with you
you'd listen would you [ __ ] listen
[ __ ] just nervous now no don't be
nervous
right and there would be like like an
old boy just a little latch and read put
foods in there right but like like
healthy no no sugar no carbs right maybe
I'll put one of those shake weights in
there just took an exercise meeting
sorry all right and then you you for a
year you'd be down there Wow yeah hey
Bobby what year is it yeah I would say
oh it's too
whatever if you're not ready because
you're [ __ ] still only you know 285
you would have to get down to 120 oh my
god Beatriz Johnson he's not even once
funny you know but that's what I would
do that's love
oh my god it's a great show and I love
it and then there was another we already
talked that body bizarre we talked about
that yeah but that's another good one I
like reality shows in that way
[Music]